через півроку після початку
повномасштабного вторгнення РФ в Україну
17-річна Анастасія з Краматорська може
знову посміхатися і намагається
відволіктися від новин про обстріли
рідного міста улюбленою справою завдяки
евакуації до Німеччини в неї знову є
можливість тренуватися
зробити
гарний настрій Для мене вони також
відволікаються разом зі мною гра Мені
допомагає забути хоча б на час про
небезпеку
гравчині національної збірної України з
водного поло зараз тренуються в боку ми
разом із німецькими плавчинями з
бундесліги двоє українок гратимуть у
першій бундеслізі а в другій планують
створити суто українську команду дівчата
вже подружилися Українки вчать німецьку
А німкені підхоплюють українську
може щось сказати українською
давай давай
я більше не можу
Як вам в Німеччині трохи складно правда
але супер
дівчата розминаються перед тим як зайти
у воду тренерка Олександра Мироненко
навантажує їх тренуваннями щоб
відволікти від думок про війну та
мотивують дівчат боротися у спорті і як
українські захисники на фронті
Олександра жила у Харківському районі
салтівка які нині постійно обстрілюють
російські війська кожний раз коли я
читаю новини у мене підкошуються ноги
мені дуже некомфортно знаходиться
тут коли там залишилася мої друзі моя
бабуся дуже важко коли почалася війна
спортивний клуб облав Vice у бохомі
одразу запропонував допомогу і став
рятувати український спортсменок
німецькі тренер і менеджери клубу знали
своїх українських колег за різними
турнірами і швидко організували автобуси
для евакуації
коли почалася війна маючи гарні контакти
в Україні ми майже 100 дівчат хлопців та
їхніх мамам автобусами привезли через
кордон сюди
чекає можливість навчатися працювати
надається інша допомога
але перш за все вони тут інтегруються
через спорт завдяки спорту можна
заспокоїти душу отримувати задоволення
сміятися і відволіктися від жахіття і
вони пережили і це для нас дуже важливо
Зараз обухімі який є містом побратимом
Донецька тренуються близько 20
українських спортсменок Вони все ще
адаптуються почали вивчати німецьку у
тренерки саме ісвід на рівень А1
дякую Будемо чекати
До побачення в Україні лише 5 команд з
водного поло і цей вид спорту за словами
дівчат не такі популярні як у Німеччині
тут більше матчів та команд і відповідно
Українки зможуть отримати більше досвіду
в змаганнях Хоча і сумують за різними
містами
потрапила у сусідній будинок Но в мене
вулиці
мої друзі які знаходяться тут та
тренування які змагання та тренерах Бог
у міських спортклупу допоміг українкам
не лише з місцем для тренувань а й з
пошуком житла та реєстрації без цієї
допомоги кажуть дівчата вони не можуть
навіть уявити щоб з ними Було разом з
німкенями вони вже стали друзями та
однієї команди час від часу після
тренувань збирається на вечерю тренерки
коли сумують за борщем Та хочуть
поділитися своїми переживаннями
дуже тяжко Коли я бачу всі ці новини
Мені дуже сумно становище
серце обливається кров я не знаю
хочеться плакати завжди дуже сумно Тут
дуже часто літають літаки та делікапери
і коли я чую цей звук в мене спочатку
мені було дуже страшно бо якісь флешбеки
з України були але зараз вже трішки
звикли це не так сильно на мене
[оплески]
спортсменки кажуть що коли вони у воді
то відчувають себе краще бо вода наче
змиває їхню тривогу і біль тренер теж
підбадьорює і сортує щоб боротьба у воді
та спільна ненависть до тренера
об'єднують